now moving on to something you can look
forward to next weekend is stand-up
comedian actress and author I might add
Angela Johnson Reyes she is joining us
live welcome to the show
hello thank you for having me oh it's so
good to see you I personally Bon Qui Qui
the nail salon sketches you've done many
many years ago when I was growing yeah
and they're still so funny till this day
you know what's funny when people tell
me that I'll run into girls either at my
show or whatever they're like oh my gosh
I grew up watching your videos and I'm
like wait we're not the same age but
hold on wait a minute right exactly but
you wouldn't you look the same age thank
you you guys think you look the same
exactly now where did you get your
inspiration for sketches like that
you know my comedy comes from real life
right everything that I talk about has
been something I've experienced somebody
in my life it's based on my brother it's
based on my grandpa it's all of my
comedy is from real life and I think
that's why like my favorite compliments
to get from people is they're like after
a show the book oh my God we would be
best friends if you lived in Tulsa we
would be besties you know like that's
that's always my favorite is like
connecting with people on just real life
stuff definitely growing up I always
knew she would be so much fun to hang
out with and just do these sketches
together and just chit chat about life
together but before you were a comedian
you were a dancer so can I just go ahead
and say this to Raider Nation
Angela was a former raiderette or is a
former raiderette yeah yeah thank you I
I was a cheerleader for the Oakland
Raiders that I now like to refer to as
the Oakland Raiders of Las Vegas
uh but uh yes I cheered for the Raiders
2002-2003. we went to the Super Bowl
that year it was a great year to be a
cheerleader for the Raiders man well
hopefully on November 11th you're gonna
bring that good luck to our Raiders here
in Las Vegas okay yes yeah I plan on I
think that'll be my first game I'm gonna
go that weekend I have my show on Friday
at Treasure Island that I'm gonna stay
for the weekend and go see the Raiders
on Sunday oh my God that's so good okay
so what can people expect at your show
uh so this hour that I'm talking about
now is my life after covet things that
have changed for me moving being a
California girl born and raised moving
to the south in Nashville and like all
the different things that happen like
I've learned you know when I go to a
restaurant in the South and I order an
iced tea they it automatically comes
with three pounds of sugar in it
and they call it sweet tea I call it
diabetes like it's just it's different
in this style that's so funny I love
that you've Incorporated so many
different cultures within your comedy
you've lived many lives at this point
oh yeah I talk about anything in my life
so I'm living in the South and I go to
TJ Maxx and I hear the ladies in the row
next to me can I help you find anything
I'm all right but thank you so much for
asking like whoever I'm near you're now
part of my show I love that Angela tell
everybody about the book that you have
right now that people can get if they
can't catch you on stage
my book is called who do I think I am
stories of Chola wishes and caviar
dreams so you can check that out
anywhere you get books and let me tell
you that title who do I think I am as
stories of self-identity growing up
Mexican-American but I didn't speak
Spanish my last name was Johnson I
wanted to be a chola real bad it's all
of these stories it's everything it's
chasing my dreams it's all how I got to
where I am today thank you and that's
who do I think I am thank you so much
Angelina